in lieu of a proper GDC talk Sony held a
live stream that featured ps5 lead
architect mark Cerny breaking down the
technical specifications of the new
console from SSDs to backwards
compatibility here's what you need to
know from sir knees talk first load
times sir he began his talk with the ps5
solid-state drive which has a base
transfer speed of five gigs a second
that means games will load an impressive
100 times faster on PS 5 than ps4 Sony
wants to say goodbye to loading screens
let's talk about the size of that SSD
the PS 5 will ship with an 825 gigabyte
Drive which is an unusual size Sony
arrived at this number by collecting
data on the top 100 most played ps4
games cerny believes that 825 gigs is
enough for players as installing and
uninstalling games is intended to be a
much easier process with the new console
generation but if that's not enough for
you you will be able to add more storage
to the PS 5 however only certain SSDs
will be compatible you'll need to make
sure you're using m2 drives with PCIe
4.0 supports otherwise they won't work
and don't worry
Sony will specify which drives you need
to use let's talk graphics the PS 5 uses
a custom AMD rDNA to GPU Sony didn't
just slap an existing graphics card onto
the console this partnership with AMD
could lead to some technical findings
for the next commercially available AMD
card so when you play your PS 5 later
this year you'll be doing so on
cutting-edge technology as for the games
you'll be playing sony aims to make the
100 most popular ps4 games backwards
compatible at launch and more will be
vetted on a case-by-case basis sony an
AMD are taking backwards compatibility
very seriously with the PS 5 so while
not every single ps4 game will run out
of the box it is a key feature moving
forward expect your PS 5 to run pretty
quiet while playing those games too I
know from personal experience that a ps4
can sound like a jet engine leaving the
runway and Cerny acknowledged these
large fluctuations and fan speeds as the
console heats up the PS 5 is designed to
consume the same amount of power
at all times preventing fans from
spinning up and causing a racket
speaking of sound the ps5 will also
deliver enhanced 3d audio Surrey claims
that Sony's proprietary tempest 3d audio
tech can simulate hundreds of sound
sources think about what ray-tracing
does for light causing it to naturally
bounce around objects but for sound the
idea is that if you hear a sound while
playing a game you should be able to
identify exactly where it came from
we learned a lot from cern EES ps5
presentation but there's still so much
we don't know what does the PS 5
actually look like how much will it cost
it's coming this holiday season but when
stay tuned to game spot as we chase down
the answers
[Music]
[Music]